Did you fall in love with Fleabag?
Well, start getting used to life without her
endlessly witty remarks.
"They're good, right?
Chic."
"'Chic' means 'boring.'
Don't tell the French."
Series mastermind Phoebe Waller-Bridge created,
wrote, and starred in the hit show, portraying
a young woman who uses sex, humor, and an
imaginary audience to cope with difficult
emotions.
Well, Waller-Bridge just revealed that the
Emmy-winning show won't be getting a third
season at least not anytime soon.
Please note: In case you aren't completely
caught up with Fleabag, there's going to be
some spoilers ahead.
During an appearance on Late Night with Seth
Meyers, Waller-Bridge revealed that she has
no immediate plans to revisit Fleabag a character
she originally conceived on the fly for a
stand-up sketch.
"Yeah, I quite like the idea of coming back
to her — well, me — when I'm 50 'cause
I feel like she would've had more life then,
and God knows what she would've got up to."
She goes on to say:
"Actually, seeing a character like that in
her later stage of life is exciting, but for
now, she's been through enough.
We've got to let her go."
In fact, Waller-Bridge never even planned
for Fleabag to get a second season.
In August 2019, she told Jimmy Fallon on The
Tonight Show that
"I was very smug about not coming back because
I thought I had a lot of artistic integrity
in not coming back after the first one.
Because the first season had a proper ending
in my mind."
Based on Waller-Bridge's 2013 one-woman show,
Fleabag eventually did receive a fantastic
second season which centered around Fleabag
falling in love with Andrew Scott's "Hot Priest."
Since a second season wasn't originally in
the cards, it's easy to believe Waller-Bridge
will eventually change her mind about making
a third season.
While that's certainly a possibility, it sounds
like it probably won't happen for a few decades
but really, it might be best if it doesn't
happen at all.
It's rare to find a series as well-written,
funny, and moving as Fleabag so it's only
natural to want new episodes to come out every
year.
That said, it's also rare that a series maintains
such a high level of quality throughout multiple
seasons.
Both seasons of Fleabag were nothing short
of marvellous.
The show was pitch-perfect and expertly executed
from the first scene to the last … a scene
that finds Fleabag and the Priest confessing
their love for one another.
"No, let's just leave that out there just
for a second on its own."
Then, they say a tearful goodbye and split
up with smiles on their faces.
This unexpectedly touching ending caps off
the unique love story of Fleabag and The Priest,
setting The Priest back on the right path,
and putting Fleabag on a path where she can
start to heal and eventually shake off her
self-destructive tendencies.
This conclusion also leaves the story wide
open and on a surprisingly hopeful note.
Fleabag and the Priest can hold the memory
of each other in their hearts, and the two
of them can realize their personal goals independently.
In the first season, Fleabag finds numerous
ways to avoid dealing with her grief and trauma
… and she finally begins to confront these
issues in the second season.
That made the series finale poignant in all
the right places, and it never got overly
soapy.
Fleabag realizes that she needs to stand on
her own two legs without constantly checking
in with the audience that only she can see.
As Vulture's Kathryn VanArendonk put it,
"She ends the story she's been telling us
while also turning toward her own life, her
own family, her own relationships with people
who can speak back to her.
It's why the ending is such a perfect conclusion
to the series, and why it also feels so crushing.
In the end, Fleabag breaks up with us."
Breaking up is never easy to do... but sometimes,
it's necessary.
And when it comes to Fleabag, it's definitely
for the best.
Check out one of our newest videos right here.
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.